merci au choix je t'aime bon allez 18h39
tout le monde c'est pas rien
les plus personne ne me faire l'émission
avec moi je suis seul avec le public
[Applaudissements]
venez et venez et sont tous dehors ils
doivent faire un toc toc toc venez on
fait une barre car on les fait que
jamais rentré
tim faire l'émission avec moi
aujourd'hui hier date chez rim étoiles à
aller vadim étoiles à mes toiles
habitants laval nîmes étoile mais toi là
à vadim étoiles et toiles à ces régates
3 bien l'arrêt chéri gala c'est toi bien
là bas tu chéris la saison passée le
grand père jim étoiles à toi bien là mon
chéri toi bien là mais elles avaient
tiré à toi les attend et toi bien même
si régime de vin doux
alors qu'une place se bat là-bas mais
toi la part de toi là-bas ma chérie mais
toi là-bas et toi dans toi là et pour la
meilleure école aba à côté d'eux du
grand père d'eddy lundi mais toi là-bas
on tapait dans la semaine à chicago les
white second va vous équiper à d'accord
on va faire connaissance avec vous et on
va voir son et téléspectateurs qui vont
décider si on fait contrer les
chroniqueurs ou pas c'est parti g ils
sont là c'est le chroniqueur que vous
aimez que vous préférez ils sont autour
de la table
ils sont là ils sont chauds dont par les
médias n'ont parlé de tout ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui
attention on va démarrer par là mon ami
salut match et rip au micro c'est parti
comment tu t'appelles alicia comment tu
te situes alicia alicia tu as quel âge
17 1 10 17 on vit si tu fais tes pas à
l'école
est-ce anouma s'est pas jean-luc lahaye
qui présente l'émission là
alanis à aller certain temps quelle
classe est probable ni trop dans la mine
elle terminal quoi smg et maintenant il
ya les terminales on les comprend pas
mon frère à l'époque tu avais des
terminales l littéraire gay est sûre
typique maintenant ouais je suis en
terminale s aiment dbg way société
médicale des beaux gosses ont fleuri
balle ça imprime douvres maintenant tu
as des terminales were tu sais pas tu
comprends pas ça veut dire quoi tu fais
quoi alors bon bah merci d'être là c'est
qui c'est quoi
merci tu es content d'être là oui super
content c'est vrai ma boîte et kamel
bonjour bonsoir saluer on se régler on
dirait valérie bénaïm mais en dordogne
comment tu t'appelles mathieu laura
laura oui j'aime bien alors on aime bien
le cuir apparemment non alors je peux
demander à tout le monde et jeune tu as
quel âge 35 ans 35 ans qu'est ce tu fais
dans la vie à six sont commerciales dans
quoi dans une société de courtage en
crédit immobilier et l on voit qu'elle
est sûre d'elle elle elle fait cette
télé mais il se dit je vais pas rester
longtemps dans la société
c'est le cas de remarques je me barre
direct je me barre direct en télé quoi
je suis très heureux d'être là
c'est vrai que ça fait très longtemps
que je vous rencontrer c'est pas vrai et
participe à l'émission et je vous
retrouverai très content le trop peu
beau à la télé
attendez moi tournée outre
sentimentalement toi alors je suis marié
démaria wifi avec we s'intitule celui-ci
greg craig
tout à l'heure je connais permien à
moins bien sûr greg david gray qui fait
quoi lui lui il a une société dans le
bâtiment lui il a une société dans
laquelle on dirait une pub lui qu'il a
une société dans le bâtiment ainsi elle
est basse au micro la la la la la
on dirait le frère de maxime gainey a
battu tati tu saches l'aï dit son prénom
mon frère on dirait qu'il me dit kemal
octobre mais tout faire dire son prénom
sochaux tu fais quoi dans la vie mon
gars troisième année en journalisme
alors t'as quel âge j'ai 21 ans et à 21
en troisième année oui mes frères mois
21 ans je tends troisième tout court
j'étais pâmé pas d'année quoi et alors
est à une fiancée tard oui non plus lui
qui lance paradis où elle a atteint les
côtes à table sur 6 elle est là elle est
là oui c'est elle c'est loïc un lâche on
s'appelle colis d'un colis mme bah
écoutes je suis content que ça se passe
bien entre vous parce que je sais qu'il
n'était pas chaude surtout au début
je voulais vraiment vous remercier parce
que chaque soir vous attend à la télé on
rigole et vous avez vu sacha il a pris
le micro on dirait qu'il va faire et aux
bruissements vacances n'a pas stoppé
[Applaudissements]
popopopop commente intitule tu ophélie
ophélie wells additionnel ça va être
j'aime bien au final fait que des bosses
comme à ce sujet je m'appelle au finish
sur un stage sur un stade je m'appelle
aux fêtards ouais ça va tu en arrives tu
fais quoi dans la vie je travaille en
parfumerie
non s'ils n'oublient pas que travaille
chez ses maîtres à quoi un chien en ce
moment je suis un pochon mal non ouais
ouais pour ya plus de parfums fait
classe pour moi pour l'instant la pas
d'accord non cités pas d'ailleurs t'as
quel âge 24 ans tuée fiancée marié il
angers personnes alors il y à lui qui va
bientôt scribe libéré il est en cours de
libération d'accord machine mais en tout
cas merci d'être là tu es contentia très
content de passer la première fois vous
voyez vous voyez un petit peu les moyens
de l'émission puisqu'on a un micro pour
nos 100 personnes
merci mme kelly pence alors j'adore
maîtresse au ma maîtresse ne touche pas
[Applaudissements]
je veux travailler
il fera reculer m
interview
d'abord comment tu t'appelles match les
mecquois tepa et bientôt mais pourquoi
la peau va la passer pâques est inquiète
tu fais toi tu t'inquiètes je vais te
mettre un fauteuil se met tout ce que tu
veux tu inquiet passé pour mon salut
mais bien sûr daniel d'après tutoriaux
sans toi maintenant les séries oui tard
ça est très cool
alors comment tu t'appelles emilia
emilia j'aime bien tu as quel âge 18 ans
18 ans pile ça passe je sais toi t'as
17e mais c'est ma soeur c'est ta soeur
mais vous êtes donc de la même famille
oui mais que signifie cette mascarade
non c'est vrai mais vous êtes magnifique
tout les merci pour tout et la grande
soeur ouais mais on dirait que c'est de
la grande soeur était temps mais non
mais je le sais je sais que vous le dis
tout le temps mais c'est ouf quoi tu
fais quoi toi je suis en prépa hec quoi
ouais prépa hec
oui prépare un oui je suis en
préparation h sur qui on prépare aussi
mettez une tête c'est ouf pas bravo
merci aux gens t'aiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]